it's all good
you gotta thanks for being here you've
got a you got a big movie out
yeah that's going very well for you and
you uh congratulations you have a new
baby is that right new baby uh girl
a month old right now yeah thank you
thank you and it's amazing because i
have a 21 month old girl
as well and when you ha i had her and uh
you think you're going to love this
this is the only child you're going to
love and the fact that you're having
another one
uh you know you don't think you'll be
able to love it as much because you
think you know but
they say you adjust and it's amazing how
you love your kids equally
and uh it's not true i don't care for
the second one
i want to feel it i want to feel the
love i just don't i don't know what to
do yeah
it's just i can't fake it anymore either
i don't know what to do
don't feel bad no we're going to have
another baby so this one has someone to
play with
good job sensitive to it very good
you're taking care of it yeah
absolutely now you're finding it is it
easier
with the second child there's a the
first time you have a kid you go through
so much the second time is it anything
it's
very yeah it's very intense the first
child because you're so worried about
them i remember being in the hospital
with the first child and the nurse would
come in
and say we're going to take the baby to
measure her and do the stuff clean and i
say you know what you're not going
i'm going to go with you you know
wherever you go because you it's your
kid
and the second one you kind of slack off
a little bit i mean
the nurses come in you don't care
literally a janitor stopped by and was
like i'm just going to
take the kid i'm like sure go ahead
clean her up
bring her back when you're done that'll
be fine not a problem at all yeah
yeah now how is your wife dealing with
now two kids uh it's it's
it's much harder right it is it is uh a
little uh crazy
because uh uh she's starting to make uh
rules with the two kids that they're
gonna be crawling around the house and
stuff and she uh
she made a rule of uh uh this kind of
annoyed me too no shoes
in the house i've heard of people that
do that no shoes anywhere you take them
off before you come in yeah and it's so
annoying because she
she makes me enforce the rule too to
people she'll be like oh look at the
movers they're can you
ask them to take their shoes off and
these guys are big guys and they're
moving stuff and
you know what you make a rule you should
enforce the damn thing i don't want to
do it yeah
sure so i got it yeah exact job right
yeah so now i got to go up to the guy
and i look i know you're moving a
700 pound refrigerator upstairs but
i'm gonna need you to take the rock
ports off
just to make it a little difficult i'm
going to need you to do it in socks
if you would i'm going to add one more
level to that i'm going to throw raisins
at you while you're doing it
just to piss you off just to see if it
works
so so what do you wear in this in the
house you wear socks then
well see this is the thing you have a
choice in my house
that's good water uh you have a choice
you can wear uh socks
or you can she has like uh i don't know
if you've seen like in hospitals where
they slip those like booties
over you see the booties over here
they're like
surgeons wearing exactly they're over
the shoes and i wear them and i hate
that because
they curl up in the front and i always
forget that i have mine when i leave the
house and then i'm always afraid i'm
gonna get in a fight with some guy and
it looks like the fat lucky charms guy
who's trying to kick someone's ass up
not too intimidating yeah yeah
now with the kids are you are you uh are
you watching their programming with them
because that's what i with my kids i got
to watch what they want to watch yeah
yeah do
you watch the sesame street and all that
you have to it's great because it's like
a babysitter you know
i mean and i love it and the problem is
you have to watch it with the kids so
you're locked into it
and uh they repeat a lot and that really
uh
pisses me off because just waiting for
new episodes of sesame street to come
it's like the sopranos you're like come
on turn it over do something
then you see one you excited you think
it's gonna be a new one and you're like
nah
near and far again that's what it is i
saw this all
the time near and far was great the
first time i loved it the first time but
it's like
come on keep me going i got it down now
i understand it yeah so
do you uh you know i this is a weird
thing and i i
we wanted to surprise you a little bit
with this uh which is
today i'm coming to work walking down
the west side and i
ran into a woman she stopped me and she
said you have kevin james on your show
tonight and i said yeah i do and she
said this is
this is crazy i'm his fifth grade
teacher and
yeah yeah she said i'm his fifth grade
teacher yeah and so we thought it might
be kind of cool if you could talk to her
mrs miss cranberry yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's her yeah yeah i branded her on
the street and so we rigged it up and
you know she can't be here in person but
she's on the phone and i think it'd be
cool if they talk
she's right here on the line oh my god
hello hey
yeah hi hi hi yes this is conan o'brien
you're
branding me today and i'm sitting right
here with kevin james would you like to
speak today
you said you would do this and you did
it yeah yeah yeah that's right
here's kevin james here you go oh kevin
hey miss cranberry oh my god oh the king
of hearts
no the king of the king of queens you
are so delightful
i was telling conan you were always a
wonderful
mathematician yes
we caught in the mess of magician
kevin what six times six
thirty-six you got it honey
[Applause]
okay six of them get sick
they die how many we got left
uh it's 94 rabbits
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much oh yeah your math
skills are good in that aren't they
yes they're very i do a little math in
there yeah
you're gonna have to count all the money
you make you're rich
take a little break um we're with kevin
james we'll be right back stick around